in El Paso each day brings new stories
of courage under fire
Eduardo Maher is only nine years old but
on Saturday he likely saved his mother's
life and Walmart a person started
shooting and my mom froze she couldn't
move so I grabbed her hand and we ran
outside and hid behind a truck Antonio
Lozada came face to face with the gunman
and was shot in the foot I did lose my
nephew right in front of me
I'll put the details but his horrible
image president Trump plans to visit El
Paso as well as Dayton Ohio on Wednesday
the local Democratic Party chairwoman
has a message for him stay away unless
he's coming to acknowledge that his
language played a part in us having been
witness to this Massacre on Saturday I
don't think that there's any need for
him to come and I think that he'll
actually only cause more damage to our
community if he does come Trump has made
restricting immigration the center of
his political platform he has described
Mexicans as criminals and rapists he
referred in obscene terms to countries
whose people seek to enter the US and
grinned at a rally when a supporter
suggested shooting migrants Holguin says
Trump's words matter his language has
consequences and we saw what those
consequences
said that immigrants are invaders and
that's the exact same language that the
shooter used in his essay that he wrote
explaining his reasons for coming
12-pound so since the beginning of the
year the Trump re-election campaign has
posted more than 2,000 immigration
themed ads on Facebook using the term
invasion University of Texas El Paso
scholar Daniel Chacon says words like
that are packed with negative meaning to
invade a you know a country or a region
it's to take it over to dominate it to
be invaded by you know by another army
it's basically what you're saying they
want to come in they want to take over
they want to take what's ours
but the El Paso Republican Party
Chairman says Trump's words are not
racist and that he is welcome in El Paso
I think the president coming here to
show that he's got concern I think is
outstanding there's a lot of people in
his community that support him certainly
many in this city will welcome Trump
with courtesy others however may feel it
is he who is invading them rob reynolds
al jazeera el paso